[Música]
en las redes se les llama
influenciadores los amas guían tus
decisiones tienen millones de seguidores
y no existen al menos en la vida real
son creaciones gráficas robots que ganan
millones de euros vendiendo sus
publicaciones a las marcas son los
embajadores de un nuevo mundo un paraíso
artificial y virtual el metaverso
para algunos puede ser un paraíso
artificial pero hoy en día lo que es
seguro es que es un verdadero paraíso
para todas las empresas que invierten
grandes sumas de dinero porque pues
porque va a ser un espacio en el que
habrá una bonificación para los primeros
que lleguen a una especie de nuevo
salvaje oeste y luego la idea de que por
supuesto no se van a poder intercambiar
no solo objetos reales comprarlos y
venderlos sino también objetos virtuales
con un enorme mercado posible tan
atractivo que también se invitará a
todos a crear sus propios objetos
autentificarlos hoy en día los
metaversos son inseparables de la idea
de crear una moneda autónoma monedas
autónomas las famosas cripto divisas así
que este es un paraíso muy real parece
que hoy en día para muchas personas con
el riesgo de la lógica que ya
encontramos en las redes sociales y que
encierra a cada uno en su propia burbuja
así que mucha esperanza mucha
preocupación ya veremos qué pasa pero
sobre todo hay que vender puentes entre
el mundo real y el virtual gracias a la
tecnología block change nfc que son
archivos informáticos que pueden
certificar el carácter original y la
trazabilidad de un objeto digital o no
la empresa ariane ofrece a las marcas la
oportunidad de crear nuevas
interacciones con sus clientes cuando se
creó internet todo se convirtió en una
copia una profusión la música las
imágenes todo es infinitamente copiables
nadie es dueño de nada hoy algo está
cambiando en el mundo digital es posible
encontrar estas dos nociones del mundo
real escasez y posesión la cual es la
aplicación directa para las marcas de
moda la aplicación
digital
la primera aplicación es el duplicado
digital del objeto físico aquí tomamos
un objeto que es una sudadera hay un
chip aquí que nos permite conectar esta
ciudad era y cuando la escaneamos con el
teléfono podemos acceder al pasaporte
digital de estos gt
esto nos dará mucha información sobre
cómo se hizo nos permitirá quizás se
revender lo más fácilmente teniendo una
prueba de autenticidad y propiedad
pudiendo conectar fácilmente con
plataformas de segunda mano
y
el segundo uso será crear objetos
puramente digitales un montón de
elementos que permitirán asociar en
nuestra vida digital la idea que tenemos
de nosotros mismos
a través de marcas que apreciamos y
formar parte de una comunidad sea
reconocido como fan de algo o de alguna
marca concreta
marca participó hoy en día ninguna casa
de moda puede ignorar el fenómeno julián
fournier el diseñador de moda y un gran
aficionado a los videojuegos
el hecho de proyectar nuestro universo
en un universo virtual como el metaverso
significa que podremos provocar en la
generación venidera un nuevo apetito por
nuestros oficios los oficios manuales
pero por ejemplo todo el mundo ha soñado
con ir a una gran fiesta con un gran
vestido de noche y desgraciadamente no
está al alcance de todo el mundo lo
sabemos muy bien como tampoco lo estará
la alfombra roja de cannes pero sigue
haciendo soñar a la gente por último si
creamos universos en el metaverso que
requieren realmente esos grandes bailes
esas grandes cenas o esas locas
alfombras rojas que todo el mundo
persigue como en hollywood la gente va a
poder vivirlos virtualmente vistiendo
placas de noche ropa de los grandes
diseñadores ropa de modistas renombrados
o incluso trajes totalmente fuera de lo
común todo ello de forma virtual para
luego poder proyectarse dentro de estos
metaversos
los metaversos son prometedores
el problema es que sabemos muy bien que
en nuestra época la gente puede estar
muy encerrada la gente puede estar muy
sola en relación con una identidad
social sexual o intelectual y por lo
tanto el hecho de brindarles está
ventana en el metaverso que la gente
podrá abrir les dará la oportunidad de
definirse y de conocer a otras personas
va a haber mucho trabajo de construcción
en torno a eso pero al final eso es lo
que va a suceder y el metaverso solo sea
interesante si desafía lo virtual a
cambiar lo real obviamente
pero son mundos que tendremos que
aprender a domesticar
y el modelo de negocio de los metaversos
sigue siendo el de las redes sociales es
un gran desastre que es lo que puede
ocurrir allí y que las desigualdades del
mundo real se puedan encontrar ahí
evidentemente desigualdades sociales
entre personas capaces de entender la
lógica de estas redes de entender las
trampas y de desconfiar de ellas y luego
también las desigualdades psicológicas
porque un cierto número de personas
probablemente se mantendrá alejado de lo
positivo por miedo por ansiedad y otras
personas caerán en prácticas compulsivas
también repetitivas por fragilidad
personal así que todas las fragilidades
y desigualdades que encontramos en el
mundo real es probable que se encuentren
en los metaversos pero agravadas y por
eso tenemos que estar muy atentos a los
algoritmos que regularán estos
metaversos
un mundo nuevo y extraño pero en el que
nunca debemos olvidar que cuando
hablamos con una máquina en realidad
estamos hablando con el hombre o la
mujer que la diseñó